so yesterday I was talking about what we
learned about Hillary Clinton speeches
to Wall Street companies and banks
etcetera and my view was we didn't
really learn anything surprising at all
we basically confirmed that Hillary
Clinton is a centrist center left center
right elected official we learned that
Hillary Clinton has a public and private
positions on different issues we learned
that Hillary Clinton is a status quo
neoliberal plutocrat in every way that
we expected and for me the real scandal
is the recently redeep released
additional WikiLeaks email so yesterday
in the last 24 hours an additional
thousand or 1200 additional emails have
been exposed by WikiLeaks related to
campaign chairman John Podesta email and
the real story for me is not that
Hillary Clinton said basically what
everyone thought she was saying to Wall
Street firms but rather that there was
corrupt collusion going on truly
dishonest and deceptive collusion
between corporate media the Democratic
National Committee and the Hillary
Clinton campaign now this isn't a
critique specifically of Hillary Clinton
it's not a specific rity good John
Podesta it's not a specific rity
commedia it is everything it goes up and
down the chain and I'll just give you a
few examples of this okay there's an
email from CNBC's John Harwood from
March of 2016 which I will show you
congratulating the Clinton campaign up
for a good performance now why is this a
big deal will a few months earlier John
Harwood had moderated a debate alright
fine i mean moderators are going to be
voting for someone this was after he
moderated the debate you could have the
same issue the republican moderator but
but would they be in touch with the
campaign chairperson of a campaign not
really sure about that harwood in
several emails to clinton campaign
chairman John Podesta is just showering
Hillary in praise and it of course does
bring up questions about was this
someone who is able to be a fair
moderator during that primary debate but
it gets much worse than this okay here's
another example
the Boston Globe op-ed editor Marjorie
Pritchard was working directly with John
Podesta on the way to get Hillary
Clinton the biggest possible possible
presence in New Hampshire and there's an
email of Pritchard writing to Podesta
where she says it would be good to get
it in on Tuesday when she's in New
Hampshire that would give her a big
presence on Tuesday with the piece and
on Wednesday with the news story please
let me know this is the type of
conversation that you would normally see
between a candidate candidates campaign
and the PR agency or the party
supporting them but with the Boston
Globe sounds like the Boston Globe was
doing PR for Hillary Clinton and that
then it goes even further there's a
document with a July of 2015 media plan
were the New York Times magazines chief
national correspondent Mark leave a
[ __ ] is described as sympathetic and
this really became obvious as a result
of these email leaks because on July
seventh leave a [ __ ] did an interview
of Hillary Clinton and uh the then
there's a an email exchange where
Hillary's communications director
Jennifer Palmieri is basically told
here's the transcript of the interview
we did with Hillary Clinton before we
use this to write an article you can
veto any parts that you don't want
included in the interview and I you can
check out I spent a while yesterday
looking at a number of these different
emails and Jennifer Palmieri writes back
and says okay I cut this out cut that
out remove these two references and then
everything after X line you can use and
this is PR type crafting of what the
interview is ultimately going to say
this is a very very serious collusion
that should be concerning to everybody
who wants to believe that what we're
seeing in print and on TV has some level
of respectability and honesty there's
one other issue I want to mention which
is there a big deal has been made out of
an email that seems to suggest that
donna Brazile the current head of the
DNC in Venice CNN contributor was
letting the
in campaign know that in a debate there
was going to be a question about the
death penalty that's the way it looked
but it actually seems as though this
this was uh just donna Brazile asking
for clarification about what the death
penalty position is for an interview
that she would be doing on CNN that that
doesn't really seem like a scandal to me
the other thing from these really
disgusting leaks that i don't think is a
big deal but a lot of others do so i
want to mention it is there's an email
which i'll put up for you which refers
to hillary clinton hating everyday
Americans and a line from the email uh
from Jennifer Palmieri to John Podesta
is I know she has begun to hate every
day Americans people are blowing up
saying WOW Hillary hates everyday
Americans they're talking about language
for speeches here and clearly what they
mean is Hillary is not liking using the
term everyday Americans in these uh
speeches it's sort of a phrase or a
linguistic discussion so a lot here this
to me far more disturbing Rachel than
what we learned about the content of her
speeches to Wall Street this collusion
is really really sickening I agree with
that but I think another issue is that
it it's it's kind of easy to take some
of it out of context when it really
maybe just was a strategy for instance
in there talking about timing of the
announcement of her opposition to the
Keystone pipeline in order to kind of
ria redirect focus away from her emails
is that terrible is that just strategy i
that is absolutely strategy now you're
completely right that a lot of these
emails are internal campaign stuff and
there's no doubt that the same way any
politician wants to manage the timing of
announcements to either distract from
bad news or put the focus on something
that's more positive there's no doubt
about that my issue is as you page
through it the coordination and lack of
independence that is exposed for so many
media outlets if you ever were doubting
the importance of independent media
whether Hillary Clinton wins or loses
these emails should absolutely shatter
and destroy that I can assure you we've
cord
aided with no one in spite spite of
people saying I'm a shill for Hillary
Clinton up months ago we were told that
we were shilling for Bernie Sanders and
we must been paid by him now that I say
Hillary Clinton is the least bad option
people are saying clearly your shilling
and coordinating with Hillary Clinton
how much is the DNC paying you I am
presenting my opinions Rachel present
her opinions Pat present his opinions to
my knowledge I hope you guys aren't
going to tell me I'm missing something
neither of you has been paid by the
Clinton campaign or any other campaign I
haven't either we are going to need
independent media more than ever that is
for damn sure and these emails prove
that